[Music]
so guys it's been four days today since
we lost Kobe but Mamba Kobe mama and a
very very tragic helicopter crash on
Sunday in Calabasas along with this 13
year old daughter and seven other
victims seven yeah it was totaled now
yeah that's a lot of people in a
helicopter yeah what's a pretty baller
helicopter I saw a picture will it yeah
it's not just like that the type where
it's just two people and they have like
the Princess Leia looking things it's
like you're muffs I don't know yeah
Princess Leia hold holder yeah it was
more like I don't know look almost like
a luxurious RV like a movie trailer RV
wow I think I think um there were
teammates of his daughter since he's
like they were going to a high school
basketball game right right so yeah I'm
just this is one that I've been dreading
man I just I'd like as soon as I heard
I'm like whoa this [ __ ] hurts like it
hurt the crazy part to me so that like
so I grew up on him right so when I
remember the exact day when I was in
junior high he his his his story was
widespread because he came straight out
of high school didn't play college
that's how freaking good he was and so
yeah so like I watched him play like
he's one of the very few players that's
had to have stuck to one team and one
team only so he's identifies with the
Lakers and him and Lakers are one and so
when he passed away I'm like oh [ __ ] I
didn't think I would ever get like that
take him back by an athlete passing away
but then to see that the whole world
sure I understand people in that lady
yeah I thought it was a la thing but
then when the whole world all chimed in
I'm like wow he made a big impact that's
crazy yeah just yeah there's just so
much to say about his life too like he
was the 18-time all-star he won three
consecutive NBA titles from 2000 2012 r2
with Shaq and then he later won two more
in 2009-2010 he was the MVP in 2008
there's just and then he won an Oscar
for his Oscar yeah you won an Oscar for
a short film deer basketball yeah I was
like is this space cam that could have
been I could have been no no but like
did he work on it right - with you a
stunt double yeah he was definitely not
in space yeah I will say yeah LeBron's
cause being a second one I think Bugs
Bunny was in that one he was you know
the the space guy with the helmet
remember that guy Marvin the Martian
yeah Marvin the Martian all Martin
Martian he didn't have a mouth you trust
him yep it's just like this what's crazy
but Cobie is like my mom does not want
basketball and she said like it's like
she said why she's that it's just one of
those things where it's like when
Michael Jordan came on the scene
everybody who didn't even watch
basketball knew who Michael Jordan was
like we're interested in his career he's
such an icon yeah he's just yeah just
did something so different like I'll
never forget my mom um like making me
sit there and watch some [ __ ] a show
so that I could watch Michael Jackson
moonwalk because it had never she'd
never seen anything like it before it's
kind of like that were with Michael
Jordan to where he was just doing
something that people hadn't seen before
he was just wrecking it and dunking and
[ __ ] and one of the one of my favorite
memes is uh this is back in the day
where they had Kobe like he tore it is I
think achilles tendon and had like
broken fingers and he says without any
like a peep you pretty much finished the
game LeBron like twisted his ankle and
he has like two other people carrying
him out and so like that that was like
that's that's the Kobe I think that
people respect he just shuts the [ __ ] up
get the work done
no one knows all the hard work he does
and all the pain he goes through and I
think that's why it became such an icon
don't you love how in our culture we
can't just say someone's great we have
to say someone else sucks it's so stupid
it's like hate to to show you how great
Kobe is member one LeBron be a [ __ ]
like surpass him and points to and like
just one day yeah yeah that's what I
can't believe about it too is that he is
gone and and that every time I see his
picture every time I see something about
him
I can't think the dream it was like four
days ago he was hot and I keep scrolling
through social media like r.i.p Kobe
Bryant like though that just doesn't
make sense it just doesn't compute every
time I read it I'm like Kobe Bryant's
death I'm like that's why I'm not even
sick cuz I'm like he's not gone it could
be unhealthy
yeah like deep down inside I've been
feeling like that for the last four days
too but then last night when I was
reading into this and they were saying
like yeah they've they've confirmed his
with his fingerprints like they Richard
it was him yes I thought he went into
hiding
I um I came out of the movies to the
news and like I just want to see bad boy
stur and I was like ah it was a great
way to finish the franchise whoa that's
crazy my phone my boob and all I got was
like did you hear about Kobe did you
hear about Kobe then people started
sending me the stuff and I'm just like I
was just it was such a weird feeling
very lethargic like I didn't know what
to experience first because they're just
singing so unreal like you wouldn't
think someone like Kobe would you would
hear news like that for like 30 40 years
oh he just retired a couple years ago
though he's definitely gonna get into
the broadcast thing you know he's really
involved in his daughter's basketballs
like you know I get back into acting you
know you were you never expected to hear
something like this so soon and I think
that's what hit me the hardest with him
Paul Walker
oh yeah it's he hustle that was my Elia
yeah that's what the 41 41 you know we
spend all this time trying to be
successful trying to leave build a
legacy trying to you know make
generational well for our kids and
grandkids to be good and you know when
things like this happen it really brings
mortality into like the forefront a
black man like
what is what is it all worth I know I'm
working hard I started working so hard
I'll like [ __ ] sleep I'm gonna just keep
working as Colby what would Colby do
yeah [ __ ] yeah I'm not gonna sleep
visual representation of how like the
world found out like that was like the
epicenter is like here in LA right of
like the impact of the muse is how I
pictured it was like an earthquake
happened in LA like there was like this
way like this ripple effect of everyone
realizing like how real like life is
like how short it is like how we're all
we're all feeling our mortality and it
just like is intense man like I have
never like I have cried for celebrity
debts a couple of times like Robin
Williams something that like alia like
those were the big ones for me and but
like after a day I'd be like oh damn
that's crazy they're gone and then I
move on but this one it's like look I
could easily cry about Kobe right now
and then I don't even watch basketball
you there he's just so weird I was never
a huge Kobe fan just cuz I'm for the
Midwest grew up with Michael Jordan like
I'm not even like a huge LeBron fan but
I would never deny their greatness or
their addition to the game in the crap
and I always admire the athleticism F
lettuce ISM and you know they're being
great fathers
I think that's what really resonated
with me on the different levels cuz like
I know how I feel when somebody cuts me
off in traffic how know you like what
the [ __ ] bro like just use your blinker
right but I know how infuriating I am
what I get when someone doesn't my
daughters in the car cuz in that moment
I feel so helpless I can't they clip
means I hit something else like I'm
completely helpless in that situation
and my daughter's looking at me for
guidance for help for comfort for
anything and I can't do anything and
that's what really resonated to me
because I like in those last motor I see
that his soul can find peace because to
do all of that for the kids and you know
the whole reason he takes a helicopter
so he can spend more time with the kids
it doesn't have to send traffic was a
video why he explained like you know he
takes a helicopter because he's into
traffic and
and mention it he's on a roll so much if
he can get even at 20 minutes with his
kids in the car taking him in to school
and picking him up like that's why he
does with with the helicopter through
today so he can get back in enough time
I was reading how this helicopter pilot
was saying that it was really unsafe
that day and no one would have all the
other flights were grounded yeah yeah I
think we can all agree that LA traffic
killed this man I mean there's no doubt
in my mind because traffic is so [ __ ]
bad here that you have to take a [ __ ]
chopper to live your life like you do
have to like if you have the resources
like you like dude the traffic here is
so insane and not getting any better
that if I couldn't take your [ __ ]
Robert even after all there should I
still would because it's so bad it took
me over two hours to get to Irvine and
that's like a 40-minute drive that's
what that me do ya it took me it took me
two and a half hours I had to show
Embraer last week I went to Brea I hit
it to brer around one cousin my show
wasn't into eight oh my god I just went
early got a room and camped out because
I know if I left then it'll be a 45 50
minute drive from Glendale but if I
leave at five or six two hours two and a
half hours easy yeah late and so I was
like I would rather just spend a hundred
dollars to be comfortable in the room
not being traffic not have anxiety
building up and then I had to go on
stage to do 30 minutes of stand-up like
my shoulders are [ __ ] since sale like
LA traffic is the worse that I've ever
experienced my life only like seconds to
maybe China Philip Rivers he's seriously
because Philip Rivers is he was the
scene Diego Chargers quarterback he then
they meant moved to la víctima de la he
still lived in San Diego and he would he
would he outfit in an SUV with like TV
screens and [ __ ] so that he could do all
of his pregame [ __ ] and my practice like
[ __ ] like just in the back boy he had a
driver drive him back and forth yeah cuz
it was so long he spent like three four
hours in traffic ridiculous man it is
honestly ridiculous the infrastructure
in LA is horrible for this to be as big
of a metropolitan city as it is working
on the Hyperloop hopefully yeah I'm free
weight on top of the [ __ ] freeway how
about that first just give me that
Oh
like even if they had a better transit
system like the bus system in LA the
metro system in LA is it's okay but it's
not efficient enough for people do
really like you can't like if you have a
job or you're in a what is it is that
you can't take public transportations
it's not efficient enough it's not it's
not timely enough I put a pin on your
shoes I mean that's gonna happen yeah
I'm messing nothing like I'm very
paranoid so like when I do like take the
train I always have like a trash bag
that I've sliced down the middle and I
place that over the seat because yeah
they like people be on those trains and
they sleep and I just pee and you just
sitting in that pee are they making that
furry fabric that I know Clark's
bacteria yeah because it's dark it's
dark it is easier to see lasting it's
like stripper chairs yeah I think Lysol
wipes it a stripper
oh that's smart - yeah just wipe down
the stool and I've seen before before
your lap dancer like going on
you know I wipe down my just where the
fall and then you'd real quick just two
jets on a [ __ ] do you guys remember
where you guys were at when you guys
heard the news hell yeah I was with Joe
Joe's the one that told me we were at we
were at a business thing and you had a
Tony Robbins seminar yeah and I was so
happy like out like we were making so
many breakthroughs and learned so much
about business and Mindy and we were
like [ __ ] yeah that's tight and he goes
Cody Brian just died and I'm like hmm
it just went black I'm like yeah good
mind dude you're lying so I went to
Twitter and I went to look and there it
was the whole time I was like Tony
Robbins tell us what you feel what you
really feel right now I know you got the
[ __ ] news and then he was doing an
interview with the owner of [ __ ]
coconut water the Zico and I'm like stop
talking about coconut water talk about
Kobe Bryant I know everybody wants to
know right now what you feel and he did
he talked about basketball a little bit
cuz I think he was about to slip but
then they finished their speech and they
stopped them like man I wanted to hear
your thoughts weird it'd be crazy if
Tony Robbins was like man [ __ ] Kobe I
know okay crazy do you think he was even
notified this is a spot check
I'm sure it for everyone knew everyone
knew because um it I think it happened
when he was gone behind behind the stage
there was someone else doing a speech
when it happened and then he came back
up on stage and then I think that's when
everyone started like thank you about
Kobe like you hear everybody talking
about it and then I'm like man we should
just talk about that right now yeah I
wish they would have yeah
you said Tony Robbins I thought you said
that they went to Tony Roma's those ribs
they're not that good like why how did
it change their life Tony Robbins I was
like wait it's not Romola Tony Roma's
first of all I can't believe you're here
this incredible does anyone know what
Tony Roma's look look look I've no idea
because I know what game puck looks like
if your Italian is even real Wow I think
there's a Tony Roma's like there's a
game pope looks like yeah he's a fat guy
with a beard
there's no beard there's no beer no beer
good for you why was he cooking for you
Winnie the Pooh style just ass out have
a big beard I don't know looks like I've
never played to either yes because you
never bought the expensive suit that's
true I mean I bought it in in the
airport but oh no the the canned
expensive soup no I'm not a treat you
never treated yourself like that that's
true I'll make my own soup okay there
you go oh wow how do you find Albert so
I was at at the Fed Expo on Sunday and I
was with one of my buddies we just flew
in out of town so he's a strength and
conditioning coach for a bunch of pro
athletes NFL players and being a
basketball players and one of the guys
he coaches was a Laker so and then that
guy DJ Cal that Nipsey Hussle I called
all
all in the same investment group
together so when he found out he was
like you're not gonna believe what just
happened and I'm just I'm just sitting
across from him we're just eating tacos
and I'm like what he goes Colby just
died and I'm like what da [ __ ]
and then like it just hit me cuz I'm
like I thought he was just gonna say
like I don't know I wasn't gonna I
wasn't expecting a celebrity to die and
Kobe he's so young it's it seems like
he's just about to start his broadcast
career like you're saying
so that caught me off guard and then
right then and there like two fans
wanted to take a picture and I was like
I still went through the motions to the
picture cuz I know they don't know what
happened but then pretty
did you know Kobe just died no I don't
want to run their day but then 30
minutes after when I walked back into
the fit Expo that's all the whispers and
murmur that you feel like the entire
Convention Center it was like guys
you're just toys that you see it's just
like the whole feeling of the FedEx was
like thirty thousand people in there it
felt weird it felt really weird like
nobody wanted to flex no more no one
wanted to flex at all well you say you
say fit Expo or FedEx I was like what
does everybody [ __ ] talking about
today man the whole time I'm like why is
packages so important right now it was
everyone's so [ __ ] acting I'm like
was anybody just shown on the Internet
you just saw it come on yeah GG college
manager and like all the [ __ ] I'm like
did anybody just wanna sit on the toilet
and you go like holy [ __ ] bubble wrap is
taking over I guess you know office
supply convention the whole time you
can't even hear a bubble wrap pops yeah
yeah there's new ones then quiet takes
all the fun out of it but I think I'll
be one of those days where I remember
forever cuz I remember the exact moment
one of those events in our lifetime that
it's like where were you when you heard
about coconut water that's [ __ ] six
seven years older than most of us like
that's and what have we done with our
lives where pieces is not getting much
that's why I'm we've done nothing he
started his career by 17 at 17 right
yeah
so he had a head start not sure
well I don't want it as bad as called me
I know that that what I heard yeah I've
read so many stories and seen so many
videos lately of like him there's one
guy bill saying like he would always
Kobe would always get to the to the
stadium before him and so he was trying
to get that before him one time when he
when he hurt his finger he's like I'm
definitely being a man and he's like
Kobe was still there before him shooting
with his left hand they would win they
would win a game and then right after
the game everyone goes home or they go
either they go party Kobe went back to
the to the court and he just would
practice his free throws so you know and
I hear sometimes I hear a lot of
quarterbacks in the NFL they they go the
backup quarterbacks and all and [ __ ]
they go like hey I like that guy over
there he's the first guy in the building
he's the last one to leave and I'm like
I don't know if it showed up on paper I
don't know if it's I don't know I don't
know if you're there yet like some of
those like they work so hard but they
still suck yeah some of those like Matt
Hasselbeck some [ __ ] I'm like oh yeah
it's good that you put the work in I
think what hurt me even more I mean
obviously it was Kobe that really really
hurt me but I I think just thinking
about his wife Vanessa and her losing
not only her husband but her her child
where I'm like [ __ ] I can't even imagine
what she must be feeling I have your
family just died that's [ __ ] crazy
like what that and like how do you
explain it to the other kids you know
like they're so little like how do you
explain that they're not coming back
anymore there's a part of me where I'm
like because of social media like when
you imagine you're in the family I
wonder how like kids or family members
feel when you feel like let's say I
learned that my dad dies through
Instagram this is through my dad in the
hospital something else that I wanted to
bring up too was like how TMZ broke the
news before a lot of the other families
found out so apparently first it was it
was reported that not even Vanessa knew
and that she found out through TMZ but
it turns out that she did know
according to Harvey Levin the TMZ guy
and so he ended up just still like
saying like you know what even though
the other families don't know yet like
this is Kobe's more important we got to
get this out and so it's like what that
song
yeah I think there needs to be some
respect for the family than that's
involved and so they should report
things late like us smart that's really
smart
oh really since my days yeah actually
longer cuz I don't know when this guy
seven days but that's enough time
respectful you could count on us that
the kids won't watch JK news and find
out but that's fun even it though some
reason I found out watching JK news [ __ ]
were you bad week well how did you [ __ ]
that out that that's a good point well
yeah like I don't know there's just a
lot of people are having issues with TMZ
not like this one is like the most
[ __ ] up one too but they've also been
like working with with LAPD to publish
like victims photos or like exploit
other women and stuff and just they have
an issue but yeah there's just so much
more it's really cover and I've just
been sitting here like just like sulking
like I just I just feel like the real
not real life I don't know I don't know
it's weird though cuz that what you just
said that there's two sides of that
right so it I've heard people say it's
incentive nobody's even talking about
the other people who died and then on
the other hand I hear if you publish
their photos you're taking advantage
then I'm like damn do you just can't win
other things like the women accusers or
whatever like oh okay other people not
these victims in particular I'm just
saying like TMZ altogether they're
they're saying times up on TMZ because
because they're just using it to exploit
yeah see got me and they maybe even have
all the facts right like when I'm sorry
for his broke they were saying it was
his five people in the helicopter Rick
Fox's kid you're like what the [ __ ] my
dad died and just kidding oh what the
[ __ ]
yeah and that's the crazy yeah baby
she's a musical artist she was like my
stepdad was not in the helicopter can
you guys stop spreading this fake news
what's she gonna say fake knows she's
like this this rumor and just let the
details like fall out because people
want to be first so bad like it's so
crazy
and we've I'm sure we've all done it at
one point or another but like it's
almost like people love Cher
bad news it's a reaction from people
like old you here so you could be the
first person to say it right because
even when I posted like I feel bad for
people leaving out the other victims and
I didn't know all the information so I
just say you know prayers up and
positive energy to all the families
affected by the horrible crash today so
and people were like yeah man to do here
his daughter was with them like mother
[ __ ] yes yes I heard that you don't
have to like put that just like yo like
respect to put up a heart or something
like all the extra [ __ ] is not necessary
we just love to like give the bad news
and I feel like that's what TMZ is like
really taking a minute for me like I
didn't even feel right like I did tweet
some stuff but like just even like on IG
yeah I had photos from like the 2010
Laker parade that yeah - and like I saw
like I got a glimpse of him in person
like all of LA was there like supporting
like I [ __ ] felt like the energy of
LA and like the love for the Lakers and
like I just felt weird like I didn't
want to make it about me yeah I'm always
conflicting when people post pictures of
somebody they just dive like yeah look
at me the person's not here no more we
took this picture and it's using not
something like like me we we met Kobe
and all deaf because he was one of the
richest investors and the hedge funds
that they sorted and like he would come
to the office he would take the
helicopter to the parking structure and
have a truck pick him up
and I still didn't post any of those
pictures cuz I just liked it I don't
want it I don't want it to seem like I'm
trying to make it about me in a personal
relationship that I have like I know but
I he didn't know me well enough to see
me in [ __ ] Jamba Juice but yeah and
that's hard oh like it's never got like
he just knew I worked at the company so
that's hard too because we all you know
there's such a there's such an
inclination in where we're at where
everyone wants to inject themselves into
the story and be like how this affected
me and I get that there's there's a
there's like a cellar it's a catharsis
as well so I don't necessarily think
it's one or the other but I do think
it's very fun to make fun of then that
is true though like you
there could be when he affected your
life most right
moment in like this but the you know
like it's their story it was the forgot
her name already but the woman ESPN girl
she ended up sharing a story about how
like when she met Kobe and she was like
eight months pregnant and yes they're
like well how far along are you and she
says like oh you know what I'm having
another girl or a girl and he was like
man I love being a girl dad liked her
sharing that story mm-hmm what's the
stop it the whole past AG man exactly
now there's all these dads talking about
like being a proud girl dad and I'm just
like things like that where it's like it
makes an impact like a beautiful impact
by sharing your story that I can I love
like I get behind I also understand the
reason why people need to share
themselves and inject themselves into
the story ends of it it's just it's just
at the end of the day I see Kobe Bryant
41 years old legend icon everything and
I think man that's only like a couple
years I'm I could have eight years left
like any of us could yeah that's that's
that's that's what really blows my mind
no mortal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]